it's been a five-day wait and finally
help has arrived
it's been very painful waiting for a
boat to get to the mainland because here
there is no food we are very hungry
among those waiting to be saved is
Fatima Fred and her child
is by the grace of God that we alive
because our friends were taken by the
water our friends are dead
there are dozens more stories like these
in makanga and Central Malawi
the area lies between two large rivers
and heavy rain and winds from Cyclone
pretty have caused intense flooding
cutting its people off from food water
electricity and health facilities
farmland and crops had been devastated a
rescue operation is being run by police
but it's limited they say they're doing
whatever they can they have some support
from the un's world food program or wfp
currently we are operating with only two
boss from the wfp again it's a huge
number of people that want to be
evacuated to Bangor which is an Upland
trace your honey is cooking the last of
her maze she tells us she survived
powerful flood waters by tying her
children to tree branches because she
could not hold on to both of them at the
same time the boats will go back and
forth for days to come so far 1 300
people have been rescued and many others
are waiting but they are victims of the
flooding who refuse to leave their homes
like those in this Village they want to
stay with their families and what they
know
in the town of bongula the situation is
only just improving but people desperate
for Refuge continue to arrive clinging
to the few possessions they've managed
to save
but bongula is also cut off from
surrounding towns and cities
but after three Cyclones in 18 months
people in this District are quickly
adjusting and just as quickly are
beginning to rebold with the little they
have
District Malawi